e
and
uh again it's uh March 4th 2025 and I'm
opening the subcommittee work session on
Allegiance I pledge of allegiance to the
FL of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation
under God indivisible liy and justice
for
all thank you everyone uh we won't be
taking any testimony uh today we'll just
be uh uh talking within ourselves which
you're more than welcome to listen to
and then we'll eventually at the end of
the uh discussion we'll be doing a
recommendation uh to the uh Full House
of Municipal and County government
committee
we can get some from you because you're
a a member of the local planning board
okay so
I I have a few
concerns um about recovery houses
first being that the house can go into
operation before it's certified that's
number
one number two is
parking and my assumption is that
because people who are resident in
recovery houses are holding down jobs
they need a means of getting two and
from their jobs and other activities
within the
community and my final
concern is with septic systems where the
recovery house is not on a Town sewer
system and I guess in order of
importance it's number three the the
septic system and how towns are are
going to be able to handle that I did a
little bit of
research and there is
statute and I'd be happy
out there is statute that
addresses uh septic
systems when a change of use occurs
which gets us back to the original
language of the bill which says that the
sober house or the recovery house has to
be treated like any other house as far
as zoning
goes the the point is that I
think this is a state law well it is a
state law and it's more of a health
than a zoning issue so I would I would
hope that the state law would kick in at
some point and my my hope would
[Music]
be that um when a house applies for
certification or actually applies to a
town they would have to certify the
design capacity of the septic system
and if the intended
occupancy exceeds the design capacity
which is usually two people per bedroom
and there are State
definitions of bedrooms room with a
closet um then the state RSA would kick
in which would require
design of a suit ably sized septic
system uh I believe before a certificate
of occupancy could be obtained and
there's actually similar language or
similar
requirement in last year's HB
1291 which was a bill having to do with
adus and if someone was going to build
an
Adu then um you would have have to have
a septic system designed not install but
a design for the additional language
and I have that statute as
well not statute it's
Bill and I believe the language for that
so I I think that's that's something
that I think I would like to see in
because it's you know it's a it's a
health and safety matter and basically
just to speak to the parking matter
which I have shared as a concern um
throughout this but I think that's also
something that's already being enforced
through ordinances and regulations that
we have in our towns where you can't
park in the road during this time of the
year and and rules that we have like
that around parking where it's already
an issue that they're going to have to
um figure out a way to work with um and
it's I don't feel that it's something
the government should be and the
municipality should be dictating when if
there was a large family that had kids
around the same age that would all have
way I I would agree with you
representative
gero
um
towns you know your you're analogy to um
families with teenage
drivers um yeah you've got to deal with
it but I'm I'm wondering if it might be
in everybody's best interest to have
something about parking in the
legislation or perhaps in the
certification uh by the certifying
organization which just kind of says to
the
operator don't you know you've got a
yeah uh similarly in Rochester we have
these old big Victorian houses that can
get got converted to two
bedroom two and three unit Apartments
the parking is designed for two cars so
we already got a problem in Rochester
with no uh excess parking for
multi-units in the old Victorian house
this would put it on a whole new level
cuz you're talking maybe maybe might be
six or seven cars in one building where
they going to park I mean you do have uh
small streets in the little
neighborhoods and they're supposed to
have all have to have off street parking
in the winter that's part of our
ordinances so they're parking up on
their lawn and whatnot but you're
talking six seven eight cars that's a
whole new level they don't have room to
park yeah no I definitely understand
that and I think that any owner of these
facilities is going to understand that
too and see that as a problem I would
just hate to see that get in the way of
us being able to help solve the issue of
both homelessness and then sobriety in
the state over a matter such as parking
when it's an issue that's going to have
anyways represent
Doan thank you um I had several
concerns that I wanted to bring up um
and a lot of it was based on the
testimony that we received in our first
subcommittee
session um I in general I I view I think
these are the recovery house more
Recovery House beds are needed we we we
need to help provide those services for
those those people who I'll I would like
to include them as in the
U purative they're the some of the most
needy Among Us uh and really need our
help but there's a big
butt when when we're caring for the
needy or for those most vulnerable I
think we need to be especially careful
that we provide them with with uh the
kind of safety and and help that that
they're really going to need I
the one of the biggest problems I have
with this bill is there's too many carve
outs in it that that when we're looking
to help these needy
folks we
exempt many of the
safety uh guard rails that we put up uh
in our communities and these are these
are the people that need those safety
guard rails when they go to bed at
night and they're perhaps a little
compromise when they go to bed whether
they're falling off the wagon or or
getting involved in
Narcotics a subsequent time the the
thing they don't need is when they wake
up at 2 in the morning and there's no
and there's and they need to exit the
building for whatever reason some type
of an emergency a fire for example if
there's no lighted exit signs to help
them navigate their way out of the
building uh which which this this type
of legislation would exempt that and say
oh it's not important to provide those
those safety uh guard rails for these
people um smoke alarms
um sprinkler systems these are all
things that that when you have people
vulnerable people like this those are
the guard rails that we as legislators
can help and put help put in place yes
in some cases it's going to make make
the the expense of maintaining that
property
higher but what's what is the price of a
life or several lives that may be lost
because of that do we do we do we want
to be the ones that call uh Mrs Smith up
and say we lost your son in a fire and
we didn't take the time to put any smoke
uh Det curent uh in the building even
though we knew they were compromised or
needy
folks uh we had some testimony
about uh Americans with Disability Act
uh
application uh and the F in our first
meeting we we take very special care to
provide that type of help for fully uh
for people that are not involved in in a
recovery house that just want to have
ACC public access to a public building
uh to so that they can go to the town
hall or they can go to the city hall or
whatever and we we bend over backwards
to make sure those doors are open that
there's enough toilets and that there
are lighted exit signs for their safety
but when we go into a a community house
that's a recovery house we give carv Val
to say you don't have to do that anymore
I I just think that would be
irresponsible on our part to to
uh to allow people to u to navigate
through these properties without those
protections
U I think it's I think we're sacrificing
safety at the wrong time and the wrong
point in their lives and this is going
to be a lot of folks we T we heard
testimony that uh that this right now
that
this this category of people represents
about 1300 beds in the state right now
and that this
change uh would help
us uh achieve the need that we have of
about
15,000 uh beds in this house do we
really want to go back to our local
communities and say hey we've we've
taken the the uh 1300 bed requirement
and up to to 15,000 oh by the way uh the
they'll they'll there's no requirement
for any site plan review or any
permitting uh that your community has in
place to be able to apply to these
things to these houses uh I I just think
that would be totally unacceptable to
the to the uh Community leaders that we
have to bring this story back to
eventually um so that that's what my
heads right now on this Mr chairman
thank you represent repres Jama thank
you um I absolutely share safety of
especially the individuals who are
vulnerable in going into these houses as
one of my main concerns but I think that
if we're looking at where they would be
if they weren't in these houses and
where they would end up whether it be um
having trouble maintaining sobriety not
in the group setting um or whether it be
going to prison or even losing a life as
we said without an exit sign um I think
we'd be I think we would see a lot more
deaths and a lot less productivity and
second chances for the most vulnerable
people in our society um if we made
that drag this bill down um but I'd like
to know what the rest of the committee
would
think represent
Frank thank you um
I'm recalling testimony from several
people that indicated that the residents
of a Recovery House are quite High
highly functioning
people um they're folks that can because
they've gone
through a a process already
they are back
to a normal life shall I say I don't
know if that's the correct
terminology but they just need a lot of
support to stay
sober and my takeaway from the testimony
was that they could live in a house by
themselves or an apartment by
themselves but because of this peer
support um
they may choose to live in a conjugate
setting with others who are in a similar
situation and I guess I draw the analogy
to do you have exit signs and emergency
exits in your house or your
apartment and I know of a very few
people who do
that
um that's my two cents on that I'm not
I'm not trying to to downplay the safety
aspect but I I want to emphasize that
the testimony that I heard was that the
residents in a Recovery House
are pretty high
functioning very high functioning rep
Dolan thank you Mr chair um and uh
representative I I I don't argue with
that point I do
I I will bring to the table today that
uh I had a uh a resident Bring me um an
example I don't have personal knowledge
of it so I kind of it's kind of hearsay
at this point but
uh a a recovery house that that he's
aware of um had a had a
problem that was
revealed to him through a freedom of
Information Act
request that uh in their recovery house
uh uh person
died uh due to an
overdose of drugs uh and so that that's
an indication that some of these folks
aren't all on the straight narrow that
they that they
are uh in
recovery hence the name recovery houses
but also with the potential of Rel abs
and and perhaps D in in
danger uh and so uh this this
information was as relate to me was was
it was
um was received again through a fouryear
request U and I think it was in the
somewhere in the conquered uh uh
walker uh my major uh issue with this
bill outside of what everybody else has
said because I share those as well is
that it exempts from all site plan
review and
codes and these were single they want to
be treated as single family
homes but before there a recovery house
they weren't single family homes they
were Apartments three and four unit
apartment
so the issues are different and it's
a issue in the neighborhoods something
like this might not fit the neighborhood
that they're being shoehorned in so and
I definitely don't like them being
exempt from any safety safety codes and
view uh rep
Jam thank you um so when I look at the
bill when I look at like the single
family two family and multif family I
think what the intention would be is not
that it turns in from a single family to
an apartment while the heads obviously
does go up a little bit um they're still
ordinances yeah but when you take and
you they find a three or four unit
building they still want to be treated
like a single family and they and it's
it's there codes a difference um the
sorry the language here would shall be
treated in every zoning ordinance as a
single family two two family or multif
family use
respectively so I think that I'm not
sure how you feel about that I think
that meets some of those concerns where
if it is already an apartment building
represent
Frack go ahead representative you so I
did actually um
receive some language it's just a rough
draft obviously but just it would be
expanding the notice that these homes
would give to
municipalities um with written notice
written notification the local governing
body at least 30 days prior to the
beginning of operations and through the
certifying body shall notify the
municipality whenever the recovery
recovery residence applies for
certification becomes certified renew
certification is denied certification or
loses certification so that's what this
language would
add thank you
wer that that's another
point is they want to get into this
these places before
certification I think they should get
into these buildings after
certification I do gen I I do agree and
that's a question that in the hearings I
also lost a asked a lot of people um I
have the certification requirements in
front of me I know it was handed out
last time um but you can't become
certified until you have the residents
in the home and they model the behavior
and responsibilities that the
certification requires of these houses
so that's the holdups there and I do
agree I would rather a certification
process where they could have a
certification day one but that's just
not how the certifications work with how
kind of in depth they want where the
too repres D yeah I I
think it kind of I kind I think we're
getting towards the end here but I think
that the way I look at this is
that some of these folks who provide
this service are doing a a wonderful
work in an area that's very much needed
for the PE for the people that it
applies
to I think that when we're trying to
craft legislation it should be to try to
help the process and try to help those
that have this need uh that we I think
we recognize is out
there however I think this legislation
doesn't do that it doesn't it doesn't
help the process in fact I think it
hinders the process and puts people who
are at risk even more at risk by uh not
requiring approvals and certifications
and and inspections and all that stuff I
I I think by I think while we're trying
to do good stuff we're not achieving
that by by relieving the requirements to
be safe and be certified so so that's
right represent
Frank so the the question or the the
conundrum
is we have a certifying organization or
perhaps more than one which says that
that their
process of
certification begins once the home is
actually
occupied
and do we as legislators have the
ability to in essence re revamp their
certification process and I don't have
the answer to that question but it seems
to me that that's a question that needs
I think if you check your emails there's
a letter from Health and Human
Services uh let me address a little bit
call
e
voluntary the one thing I would say in
regards to registry for this bill is
that this does require notification to
municipalities so it would require them
to give
notice say can say it again as far as
registry with these homes under this
bill it does require notice to the
municipality so they would have to let
their intentions be known 30 days before
opening with the language that I handed
out
um the 30-day notice do you see that
that as a conflict with the words of the
legislation that says it's it's not
subject to permitting or
approval I is you you see that not
necessarily a conflict but do you see
that as a as a conflict yeah I do I do
see what you're saying there
but it does it is contingent that you
can only have that treatment if you give
notice to the municipality 30 days
prior so so um we'd have to
amend amend the this to take take that
out or add this in or whatever yeah we
it did uh everyone have a chance to
review the email from uh Jenny O Higgins
that I sent
out concerning their position on uh well
the it talks about recovery residence
and the requirements of registry and a
few other
things and that was I don't have that
available on my phone oh
okay
uh can you can I forward it to you you
can you get email on your phone and know
yeah.net
elater I'll let you type in okay
John I don't know which button to hit to
okay okay uh any more comments from
committee I've got a couple couple of
things that I want to mention one of the
things that stand out stood out to me on
the on the bill as we got it uh it's
crossed out safe and healthy and I can't
figure out why anyone would cross out
safe and healthy and I believe I
answered the sponsor and she didn't
really have any of any answer to why
that was crossed out uh that's one
problem I have with
it because I think it should provide a
safe and healthy substance for your
living environment I don't have any
problem with not having the family like
but safe and healthy is a real concern
for me uh another concern is
the uh the certification I too agree
that they should be certified prior to
opening uh and also I think that we
shouldn't be
taking uh away the power of the local
communities uh this is something that
should be done locally they should be
able to decide and pass
regulations uh that they feel
necessary uh it appears the city of
Nashua has done something with this and
they they seem to have dealt with the
issue uh without an RSA and I think
that's great again I'm I'm very
sympathetic to uh folks that need this
uh this Avenue to pursue a a healthy
life but I also think we've got to be
concerned about their safety and uh uh
the feelings of our uh our
constituents and I think it's it's best
left on the on the local level to maybe
they can contact the city of nashille
and get a copy of their ordinance to see
how they're dealing with it and start
use that as a starting point uh but I
don't think the state should pass a a
law that tells them how to run their
communities uh and again the main thing
is safe and healthy that's one of the
primary concerns that I have and by
removing that I I don't know why anyone
would remove that from the bill that's
in the current law and I I can't figure
that go ahead representative thank you
would you be it all open to an amendment
that would add in safe and healthy back
into it I know the certification process
is definitely could be a concern since
they don't have it day one but I think
that would be a separate Avenue that we
have to go down um that would even
address the ones that are open now with
place I I would just have to say see the
see the amendment as as you as you've
written it I don't want to commit to it
because I haven't seen it yet uh but
safe and healthy uh would address one of
bill and the certification uh I guess
that would have to be done by
legislation or you know requiring the
certification maybe we could work with
Health and Human Services to get their
ideas on how to do
that maybe they can do by regulation I'm
not sure I think right now the statue
voluntary and not required right and I
think that would be something that yeah
whether this be passed or not we could
look
into of a change in the certification
make yeah yeah it already is a process
yeah just with whatever ordinances
they're
in I think that's a great idea thank
you representative Dolan you have
anything yeah I think I I would again
let me say
that this is needed recovery houses are
needed in the state but I would be much
more comfortable if we if we added them
into being ada8 compliant so that
they're they're safe and we know exactly
no matter where you look in the state we
know exactly what's going to be in those
houses that have the right number of
toilets and they have the right number
of of fire extinguishes and all that
stuff uh I don't think there's any
reason why we would want to exempt ADA
compliance other than to make it more
profitable for for the owners and that I
I don't see that as is my goal in in
examining this legislation for for owner
profitability it it's primarily for the
safety of the occupants uh that are
under
treatment thank you rep
Frack aren't a lot of these recovery
nonprofits I don't believe
so okay I don't yeah I don't have
reasons for why but I believe that that
for one reason or another it's
easier to not be a nonprofit I'm not
sure if
someone yeah okay okay I I thought we
had heard that it was a mix I think it
probably is a mix but from what I heard
in talking with people it primarily
okay so minus understand the primary
thing that we all agree on certification
as part of being
certified is that a fair assumption they
have to be
certified you on vot of that
one prior to
applying for this yeah prior to approval
approval I could be
okay uh the other concern is we have
some uh uh concerns about health and
safety of the
building and the residents and you know
if we're going to talk about prior to
approval that kind of throws a wrench
into the legislation because this is
supposedly doesn't require an approval
process according to the legislation so
that that that has to be eradicated from
the
legislation R Frack are we talking
approval by the certifying organization
or approval by the
municipality because I I see two
here I think RSA
B2 is
I think that's the uh the state
certification I I think that we're
talking you're you're right there's a
mix of approvals I but I think the one
that that I would be uh focused on is
the the land use boards in the
individual
Community to your point uh
representative I think that if we if
we're going to deny the community the
right to adjudicate things like this in
their own Community I think that's
that's a risky road to go down I think
the the um the zoning board and the
planning boards need to be involved in
in these
decisions uh and so it's not just a
state certification in my mind it's it's
the land use boards that would apply and
depending on how the
community uh town government has set
up I I would agree with you
100% um I feel very confident
in the ability of Municipal and count
government to address land used issues
but I don't feel that we have the
expertise to address the
certification of a social
service organization I I guess you would
call
it I agree uh it's it's just totally out
wheelhouse repr Jam thank you um I think
with a lot of what we're bringing up
while there's clearly a difference
[Music]
between these houses and if it were to
be eight people living in a home that
had never dealt with addiction I think a
lot of these questions wouldn't be being
asked if that wasn't a
factor so I think a lot of this is stuff
that could be looked into regardless of
this bill and that shouldn't be dragging
way we Frank on your on your current
lives these should be consider these are
considered
disabilities alcohol and and
Drug my my understanding is that under
federal law um substance abuse is
a protected class
of disability or medical condition so it
it can't be discriminated against by a
town or a state that
says you can't you know we we're going
to treat you differently than anybody
else who does not suffer from substance
abuse that's my understanding and I I
could be I could be wrong
that's the way I understand also now on
in your community you
have regulations zoning regulations and
planning regulations that address
disability
issues um other than ADA requirements we
do not we do have at least one
house which is for developmentally
disabled people
and I don't actually know if it existed
pre- zoning or if they got any kind of
special exception it's certainly
something that I would be willing to
investigate and report back to the
subcommittee um they that house happens
to be about probably 3/4 of a mile from
where I
live and from what I know it causes no
problems and the the same
organization just opened another house
in downtown
Hanover and as far as I know it is also
causing no problems but again I I'd be
very happy to investigate and report
back uh thank you representative Dolan
uh thank you Mr chair I I guess I may
start sound like a broken record here
but I this certification process that
we're we're hinting at and you know some
some uh we're we I feel like we're in
the we're kind of in the process of
inventing this certification process um
and then asking the
communities to apply it uh in in their
communities I I think it's would be much
cleaner and less um of a risk for the
communities to just in the legislation
just say that these recovery houses have
to be ADA Compliant period and then it
becomes you it's it's just an overlay
from the federal requirements you just
if you just live with the federal
requirements then you're compliant and
you from from a legislation and and a
regulation standpoint but from a caring
for the individual which is a a little
bit of a softer science I think we can
sleep better at night that we have done
the right thing for these for these
compromise
individuals uh if they if if we know
that they're going to be residing in an
ADA Compliant facility although that may
be a little more expensive for the for
the house owner it's it's safer and uh I
think it's better for the for the this
otherwise I represent
Jama thanks
um a
blanked represent Frank thank you Mr
chair
um getting back to the question of ADA
compliance and and I I'm drawing from
testimony that we heard on some of the
other bills VA um modifications
Etc uh I think but I don't know for
certain that ADA requirements only apply
to publicly accessible
buildings and ADA
requirements specifically address phys
physical
disabilities and I'm not sure that all
people in the subset of substance
abusers who are in recovery suffer
from physical disabilities that would
require any kind of
modification I'm just raising a question
okay thank you representative thank you
I got it back um yeah just to piggyback
a about off that a little bit too um
these are also issues that could be
looked into regardless of whether this
bill was passed or not looking into the
certifying process and um kind of
everything that has to do with that um
process I think if that was a concern
that would have to be done with or
legislation thank you representative
we've all done discussion pretty
much I know I
know okay uh we have to make a report
today this is our last meeting before we
uh last uh executive
session so we have
to make a recommendation to the full
committee based on the statue that we're
currently looking at uh whatever the
recommend is uh anyone is welcome to do
an amendment uh to this statute or to
this bill if they feel a feel it
appropriate okay I'll need to have some
type of motion from
someone representative
Walker I make a motion that we uh refer
to the full committee
and we have no uh no amendments in our
presence at this time correct nobody has
any amendments nobody has Amendment okay
uh any discussion on the
itl you want to talk to your motion
represent Walker I think there's just a
number of issues and we have no
amendments and we're running out of time
to get it to our
last exe exec I
meeting and I think we just itl it at
this
time thank you uh represent
Jam thank you yeah I do oppose an itl
motion um I think that this is
legislation that's really needed um and
while there are some issues that I do
feel will be fixed through an amendment
um a lot of the issues that we've
brought up today I feel like our
problems regarding less this Bill gets
signed or not and our problems whether
it be a sober living home or whether it
be eight people who have never had
addiction problem that would be going
into living a home together um so I just
think that a lot of these issues aren't
Bill thank you uh any other comments
resent
Frank uh I definitely agree with the
sentiments of Representative ger
there are lots of issues
and my thought is that the the same
issues apply
to sober
houses as apply
to college
student
um Loop homes for developmentally
disabled people as apply to
short-term rentals
even
and last week I spoke with
representative
Howland who you may remember from our
committee who is now on the housing
committee and his suggestion was to try
to get the two committees together under
I'm not quite sure what sort of an
umbrella and see if we could hash these
things out over time so that the state
has a more or less uniform
policy on residences that are occupied
by I'm going to say not
families and uh it it seems to me that
there would be a lot of
okay so I so I would go along with with
itl okay because I think it's a it's a
problem that requires a lot more study
discussion okay I'll
uh call for the vote uh this is on HB
432 this vote is the recommendation from
the uh
subcommittee to the uh full committee
based on our work session our two work
sessions
okay representative Walker
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Frack yes
Representative gerana
no and the chair votes
yes it's uh one two three four sorry Mr
sh what was the question are we voting
it yeah okay you set okay yeah uh the
vote is uh 4 to one to recommend itl to
the uh full committee again feel free
representative for amendments if you
feel appropriate okay do we have any
other business uh to come before the
committee
today no see I I'll take a u motion to
close the uh subcommittee work session
motion to close the work session second
any further discussion seeing none all
those in favor say I I thank you
everyone for taking your time to uh to
come to the subcommittee meetings I